ERIC BIDELMAN: Welcome,
everybody.
Thank you so much for coming
to Web Components.
You're going to learn a lot
in the next 40 minutes.
Thank you to everyone--
[APPLAUSE]
ERIC BIDELMAN: I haven't
started it yet.
You guys, you guys.
You might not learn anything.
You don't even know what I
have in this slide deck.
So a little bit about myself,
so you know who's up here in
front of you.
My name is Eric Bidelman.
I work on the Google
Chrome team.
I'm on the developer relations
team there.
We're going to talk about a lot
of stuff, so there might
not be enough time
for questions.
Feel free, please, tweet at me,
Google+ me, come poke me
afterwards at Office Hours.
So I have 40 minutes to cover
the future web platform, which
is a complete fail.
We could talk about this for
three days straight.
There should be a conference
devoted to Web Components.
There's so much stuff now that's
starting to even land
in browsers that it's just
amazing, and I fundamentally
think it's going to change
the way we think
about developing apps.
This is what you're
going to feel like
for the next 40 minutes.
We're going to throw a lot
of stuff your way.
Boosh!
And then hopefully, around that
35 minute mark, you'll
have this moment of zen.
Hopefully some of this stuff
will make sense, and you'll
really see where this
is trying to go.
So if you've been following Web
Components, or this term
Web Components, even at a sort
of bird's eye view, what the
heck are we talking about?
Well, we're talking about
custom elements in HTML.
You can define a new vocabulary
for HTML.
So the blink tag, for example,
is not dead.
The blink tag is
alive and well.
We can call it x-blink, and
all it is-- it's a custom
element that I've implemented
using CSS, and it just has an
opacity change using
transitions.
That's kind of a
silly example.
But you can do something like
the gangnam-style tag.
[MUSIC - PSY, "GANGNAM STYLE"]
ERIC BIDELMAN: And that's
all it does, right?
A CSS action.
So as a user of this component,
all I have to do is
include the gangnam-style tag
on my page, and I get--
[MUSIC - PSY, "GANGNAM STYLE"]
ERIC BIDELMAN: Of course,
there's more practical
examples, and maybe this one's
not practical either, but it's
not just defining new
elements in HTML.
It's actually extending
existing.
If you don't like the way the
native HTML button does its
thing, you can say a button is a
mega-button, and define that
mega-button to do something like
on a CSS transition, have
this crazy gradient, and then
when you click it--
[MOO]
ERIC BIDELMAN: It moos at you.
So defining your own,
extending-- you'll see some
more practical examples, but
that's what this is all about.
Being able to expand on
what we have in HTML.
So when I think of
Web Components--
so this ecosystem,
this umbrella
terminology for new stuff--
I think of four main areas.
I think of Shadow DOM.
This is sort of the foundational
glue, the mortar,
this is how we get
encapsulation
for free on the web.
HTML templates.
So if you're going to build a
custom element, a widget, a
component for your page, you
need to be able to scaffold
out sort of inert chunks of
markup, and then use those
later as people stamp
out your element.
Custom elements brings
all this together.
This is how you define a new tag
in HTML and put all these
lower level technologies
together.
Think of that as your
Bat utility belt.
And lastly, HTML import sort
of is used for repackaging,
repurposing.
If somebody writes this awesome
component someplace
over on the web, throws it up
on a CDN, I can then import
that into my page
and reuse that.
So we have now this proper
notion of reusability on the
web, which is awesome.
So all in all, a collection
of new API
primitives in the browser.
That's what I think about when
I hear Web Components.
And we'll talk about each of
these in this presentation.
So 40 minutes, and I have 36
to cover all this stuff.
So HTML templates is
the first beast.
This is really cool.
With one tag, we now have
proper, like, at the browser
level, the ability to template
out a certain section of
markup to be a template.
And this is great, because what
you put in this is just
DOM, right?
So I'm working with DOM, the
browser knows DOM, it's easy
to work with.
That's really awesome.
But the best part about template
is that it's parsed
and not rendered.
And basically what that means
is that things like scripts
are not going to run.
If I have a script tag in this
template, it's not going to
run until I actually stamp this
template out and use it.
So that's really cool.
Stylesheets and images aren't
going to load until I stamp
this template out.
So that's great from a
resource perspective.
You're not loading things in.
If the user never sees this
template-- maybe it's a view
or something--
you're not actually going
to waste bandwidth
until you use it.
And media's not played.
So if you had a video in here
that had autoplay true, that's
not going to do anything until
you actually invoke and stamp
this template out.
The other really nice property
about the template element is
that it's hidden from
the document.
So that basically means you
can't traverse into it.
It's in its own separate
little world.
So for an example, if I try to
query selector in and try to
rip out that comment div that I
have in my template, I'm not
going to be able to do that,
because, again, it's in its
own sort of context.
So it truly is a template that
you can use and reuse.
And so how do we
use a template?
There's two ways.
The first is there's a content
property on the template
element itself.
And that'll just give you
a document fragment.
So that'll just give
you a chunk of DOM
you can work with.
And the second is, if you want,
you can do innerHTML and
work with that.
So the process for using
a template--
clone it, grabbing that content
in any way you want,
stamp it out, and then that's
what activates it.
That's what makes the stuff
inside of it go live.
Then you see what's in it.
So by default, it's actually
display none, right?
So a quick example.
I have the same template
that I had before.
Just a blank source and
an empty comment div.
I can rip out the content
property.
And this is a great example of
showing the dynamicism of
this, right?
So I'm setting the
image source at
runtime, which is great.
I can change a template as I
need to before I stamp it out.
And then the last line
there is actually
where the magic happens.
So I'll get that content, I'll
clone its node with all its
attributes, and that's what
makes that stuff go live.
So at that point, this logo PNG
would be pulled down, if I
had stylesheets in the template,
they be pulled down,
media would be playing
if it had autoplay.
So clone, stamp out, and
then stuff goes live.
Another example.
So this is actually really
great, because it shows the
inertness of script.
So if I refresh this slide deck
1,000 times, it's never
going to run this alert--
OK, thanks, bye--
until I actually stamp
the template out.
So we'll do the exact
same thing.
This time, I'm going to
basically just going to
increment this value.
Every time I stamp it
out, an instance
is going to be created.
And then the script
will run as well.
So when I press this
run button,
hopefully that will happen.
You'll see, OK, thanks, bye.
That script is immediately
invoked when I stamp the
template out.
And I'm showing how to
increment that value.
So I'm changing the guts of
the template on the fly.
So HTML templates are a
relatively new spec, actually,
but support is actually coming
along really nicely.
So Firefox already has this,
Chrome has this now, I'm
including Opera Beta Mobile on
this, because they recently
moved to Chromium.
So very cool.
Proper at the DOM level
HTML templates.
Inert templates.
So that's the first
building block.
Quick introduction.
Let's move on to Shadow DOM.
So Shadow DOM is an absolute
complex beast.
That's not Shadow DOM.
This is also not Shadow DOM.
This is a cool car that has
the license plate SHDWDOM.
But what Shadow DOM
really is--
it gives us markup
encapsulation, it gives us DOM
encapsulation, it gives us CSS
style boundary protection.
So if you're writing a custom
widget, if you're writing a
component, you want your
widget to look
in a certain way.
You've maybe designed
it to be that way.
You don't want things bleeding
in or things bleeding out.
So it gives us style
boundaries.
And what it really does is it
exposes to us web developers
the same mechanics browser
vendors have been using to
implement their own
HTML elements.
And so I mean by that--
you might also say, well, hey,
Eric, the web already has
encapsulation.
It's the iframe, right?
The iframe is great.
We can import third party
content into our page.
But I would actually argue
it's super bloated.
For this use case, it's
super bloated.
It creates a new document
context, scripting into it is
very hard, you have to do
crazy postMessage hacks.
If you want an iframe to shrink
wrap to your content,
you have to figure that stuff
out in JavaScript, and it's
just a mess.
And for the use case of
component on a page, it's
super bloated.
But actually, what we have is
something lurking in the
shadows, no pun intended.
And so there's a couple truths
here that I want to highlight
to you right now, and that's
that DOM nodes today can
already hidden DOM, and that the
hidden DOM that they host
cannot actually be traversed
into from our scripts.
We can't actually navigate into
those or document course
lecture into them.
There's a couple of pretty
good examples actually
implemented in the web platform
today, and those are
some of the more complex
input types.
So input type date, or
input type time are
really great examples.
With my keyboard, I can
navigate these, I can
increment these, so there's
clearly something going on
under the hood here.
It's pretty interesting.
I have a little increment
widget, and there's this
boom-- there's this calendar
picker under the hood.
All I do as a user is declare
this input type date on my
page, and I get all this extra
goodness for free.
So if I actually drill
into this--
I'm an interested developer.
I want to drill into
the dev tools.
You can turn on the dev tools
under the wrench here, or the
gear, show Shadow Dom.
And so this is something
you turn on.
And then immediately when I do
that, anything that has a
Shadow Dom in the web platform,
I can drill down
into that's going to have
this little triangle.
Hopefully you guys can
see that here.
And so the input--
there's a hidden document
[INAUDIBLE].
There's a hidden Shadow DOM
attached to this input tag.
And you can see what's happening
is that the browser
vendors have implemented this
tag, the guts of it, the
internals, using nothing
but markup.
So they've used what we as web
developers have in our toolbelt--
markup-- they've implemented
that with their native widget,
not using C++ but markup.
I think it's pretty cool.
But from a user perspective, all
I have to do on this page
is just declare this element.
And there's other examples.
Video tag has all these buttons
and stuff and sliders.
Really cool.
Textarea has a Shadow DOM.
Details has a Shadow DOM.
So all in all, the browser
vendors have been
holding out on us.
Shame on them.
But now they're exposing
this to us.
They're exposing the ability
to create Shadow DOM.
And so here's a quick example of
how to actually create this
Shadow DOM.
I have my markup on the left
here-- my host element that
I'm attaching this
hidden markup to.
And what I do is I just call
a query selector for that
element, and I call
createShadowRoot.
So this is vendor
prefixed, FYI.
So createShadowRoot, and in that
shadow root's inner HTML,
I'm just going to fill
in some markup.
I'm going to put in an H2 that
says, yo, y ou got replaced.
And I'm going to put in by my
awesome content just a div.
And you can see what actually
renders, right, in that, once
I've attached that Shadow DOM,
is the Shadow DOM content.
It's not this stuff up
here-- and we'll talk
about that in a bit.
It's the Shadow DOM.
The Shadow DOM rules all.
And here's an alternative
view.
This is what you would see in
the dev tools, for instance.
You see that hidden document
fragment representing the
Shadow DOM.
So one thing that's really
important if we're creating a
custom element is you want
some style protections.
You want to be able
to style things.
Things that aren't styled are
kind of unsexy on the web.
So we have, with Shadow DOM,
the ability of style
encapsulation for free.
This is one of the great
properties of it.
So in this instance, I'm using
the same sort of inner HTML
that I was before, the
H2 and the div that
says yo, you got replaced.
But this time, I'm including
a style tag that's going to
color all of my internal H2s
red, which is exactly why you
see at the bottom that yo you
got replaced is now red.
But this is really cool, because
I have an H2 at the
top of the slide deck, right?
The slide title's an H2.
And that's not being styled
red, because again, style
encapsulation inside of my
Shadow DOM, inside of my
shadow root.
Very cool.
But we also have the ability
to control this.
So if you're creating, again,
a component, and you want to
embed this thing on your page,
maybe you have a certain look
and feel that you want
to preserve.
You don't want that thing to
look completely out of place
on your page.
You want it to be seamlessly
integrated.
So we have a couple properties
we can set.
We have reset style inheritance,
and we have apply
author styles.
Apply author styles is great.
If I turn that on, set that to
true, you can immediately see
that my Shadow DOM content is
now taking on the look and
feel of this slide deck.
Font faces are the same,
line heights are same.
Reset style inheritance
just says, at
that Shadow DOM boundary--
so there's this magical boundary
that when your
content turns rendering--
at that place, [INAUDIBLE]
define Shadow DOM, any CSS
properties that are
inheritable, just resets those.
So that's kind of
a clean slate.
That's how I can define my
own styles, and not have
inheritable properties bleed
through into my Shadow DOM and
my custom element.
All right.
Something else you probably want
to do if you're creating
a custom element is actually
provide some default
stylings for it.
So say I want my element to be
displayed block by default, or
have a transition effect when
somebody hovers over it.
This is how I can do that from
internal to my Shadow DOM.
So there's a new @host at-rule
that you can define.
So this style tag would be
inside of my Shadow DOM, and I
define inside of it.
I don't care what tag it is.
You could be gangnam-style
tag, you could be photo
[INAUDIBLE] tag, you could
be the x-blink tag.
Whatever you are, set yourself
to be opacity 0.2 and
transition with an
opacity to 1 when
somebody hovers over you.
So styling the host element or
the component you're styling--
this is how you actually
provide some
default styles for that.
You can set widths, whatever
you want to do, right?
So if you remember in the
previous example, when I
created that Shadow DOM,
everything inside of that
thing that I was attaching
myself to completely went
away, and what was rendered
was the Shadow DOM.
So you're probably saying,
hey, what's up with that?
And that's where insertion
points come in.
So insertion points are super
powerful, because they allow
you to sort of define--
I think of it as a declarative
API, but that's probably not
the best description for it.
But what I have here is the
same markup on my left.
That's my host.
That's the thing I'm going to
attach the Shadow DOM to.
My Shadow DOM is on the right,
so I'm trying to
style all H2s red.
And what I have here is a couple
of insertion points.
And so this is a way, internal
to your Shadow DOM, to define
a structure similar to that
input type date, right?
It has this crazy internal
structure.
I can define placeholders for
content from the left side,
nodes from my host node,
to then be funneled and
distributed inside of my
insertion points inside of my
Shadow DOM.
So internal structure in my
Shadow DOM, and then the user
can sort of put these nodes
where they want, and I'm
defining that internal
structure.
So content tag is your
insertion point.
And basically you use CSS
selectors to select out nodes
from the host and be funneled
into the Shadow DOM.
So this first example here is
I'm selecting out all the H2s
in my host node, and so that's
why you see the my subtitle in
the live demo at bottom.
That's why that's rendered
first, rather than this title
that I've defined in
the original host.
The second one selects out all
elements that have the class
title, so that's why you're
seeing my title, the H1 follow
that my subtitle when this
thing's actually rendered in
the browser.
I have some other markup inside
of my Shadow DOM, and
the last one, right, just says,
hey, select everything
else that wasn't selected
out previously
in insertion points.
And so everything else in here
that I haven't selected out
previously, which is why an
amazing description comes
along for the ride
at the end there.
Insertion points are crazy.
It kind of boggled my mind when
I first started learning
about them.
So I actually created a tool
to help myself and to help
everybody that wants to
learn about this.
This is a pretty cool
visualizer tool.
Everything in blue is
your host node.
These are nodes that are coming
from that host that
you're attaching
Shadow DOM to.
Yellow is Shadow DOM content,
so these are nodes and
elements defining Shadow DOM.
So you can see what I do
is I have this sort
of visualizer here.
You've got your host node, and
immediately, what the rendered
compose tree looks like is the
Shadow DOM is winning, right?
So the first thing it's
rendering is the Shadow Dom,
and as I hover over these, you
can see where they're coming
from in the different
sections.
In this header, for instance,
I have an insertion point.
It's selecting out those H2s.
One thing nice about
this is that I can
edit this on the fly.
If I try to change this
insertion point to select out
H1s, it essentially becomes a
no op in that case, right?
There's nothing that it's
selecting out, because I don't
have any H1s in my host that
are moving over to
the Shadow DOM world.
And I can also do the
same thing up here.
So if I add a bunch more H2s,
it doesn't matter where they
are, right?
That insertion point is
still going to select.
That one that's selecting the
H2s is still going to select
those out and funnel those
into the correct location
internal to my widget
Shadow DOM.
Very cool.
Very powerful, when you think
about complex widgets, and
we'll see some examples
later on.
Shadow DOM available in Chrome,
and a couple of the
mobile browsers.
But I just want to point out
there's a great session later
on actually right
in this room.
There's polyfills for
all the stuff.
So you can actually play with
this stuff today, which is
really exciting.
Shadow DOM is super complex, but
having this encapsulated
world is very, very powerful.
Templates.
Shadow DOM.
Let's talk about custom
elements.
Anybody feel like this yet?
I feel like this every day.
Custom elements.
Custom elements is sort of where
all this comes together.
It gives you with the element
tag the ability to define new
HTML elements.
So basically, if I want to
create the x-foo tag, I create
this element definition with a
name property, and the name is
the custom element name
that I'm creating.
And so the only caveat here as
you see on the little hover
here is that the name has
to have a hyphen in it.
So it's got to have
this dash in it.
Similar to regular DOM
elements-- the audio tag is a
great example.
I can create an audio tag using
the new operator in
JavaScript.
I can define a constructor on my
element as well, so people
can then use that constructor
or use the new operator to
construct my element
using new x-foo.
So that's really cool.
There's nothing different
here.
We're just defining a new
element, and you should be
able to do all the things that
you can normally do.
So until I actually have this
definition, the browser sees
this, it registers this element,
it knows about it.
x-foo, if I try to use
that, it's just
to be the HTML element.
It's not going to be
anything special.
But what you can do--
there's a new CSS pseudo class,
the unresolved pseudo
class, that you can use to
prevent things like flash of
unstyled content.
So if I want to, before the
browser knows about-- so I
have a bunch x-foos on my page,
and I'm importing those
later, maybe, I can choose to
style any unresolved element--
I can set it to opacity
is 0, so it's kind of
hidden from the user.
And then when the browser knows
about it, the x-foo tag
exists, transition
that opacity in.
So that's kind of a cool pro
tip user experience there.
You get life cycle callbacks
for everything.
So there's a ready callback
that's called.
There's an inserted callback
that's called,
and a remove callback.
And the use case here is maybe
you have a really complex
component that uses something
like index DB, right?
And you have a lot of cleanup
that you need to do before
somebody rips and removes that
DOM node from their page.
And so you want to have
things clean up.
So in your remove callback, you
would make those calls.
And so there's sort of a life
cycle of events and callbacks
for everything.
You really have insight
into what's going
on with your element.
Here's an example of creating
a definition.
Just a pretty simple, standard,
cookie cutter
element definition.
So I can put markup in here,
I can put script, I have a
section tag here.
In my registration flow, in my
restoration process for this
element, here is that
ready callback.
So when this element has been
registered in a browser, all
I'm doing is just setting its
inner text content to this
section's text content.
So it's pretty silly, but if I
right click on this guy, this
demo at the bottom here, and you
see this, just to prove to
you, hopefully you see
the x-foo down there.
And all it is, is just set
to that inner text.
It's a pretty silly custom
element, but it's just to show
you how simple it is.
And similarly to native elements
in the web platform,
you can create a
JavaScript API.
You can create an imperative
API on your element.
So in this case, if somebody
called x-foo--
the x-foo tag, they had that
element that's created in
JavaScript and called
dash.foo, they
would get an alert.
So I can define a declarative
element, but also an
imperative API for it.
So how do we use this thing once
we define this awesome
thing that's going to
change the world?
And the answer is, it's no
different than normal elements.
So I can declare it.
I can use x-foo once that
element definition is seen by
the browser.
I can create it in DOM, right?
I can create using
documentCreateElement with my x-foo.
That's the tag I'm creating.
And this example just shows you,
you can set up a click
listener, right?
And then when somebody clicks on
your element, you just call
that method you've defined
in your definition.
So we'll call that foo method
when the user clicks it.
The last way, if we have that
constructor attribute defined
on our element definition,
people can use and create our
elements with the
new operator.
So three standard ways you use
an element in HTML-- no
different than the custom
element world.
If you want, you can go
completely in JavaScript.
If you want to register an
element, create it in
JavaScript, you can do that
using document.register.
So in this example, same element
as I had before-- so
just a quick glance, right?
The section tag, the ready
callback, the foo method.
Same thing just in the
JavaScript version.
So I can use object.create, and
I'm saying, OK, create an
element for me.
We're going to be inheriting
from the HTML prototype.
So basically just a
standard element.
I'll set up that ready callback
in JavaScript on the
prototype chain.
And again, the ready callback,
in this case, all it does is
set the inner text
to I'm an x-foo.
Example of creating the
imperative API.
So I'll add that foo function
to my prototype chain, which
just alerts itself.
And the last thing here-- to
actually get this thing
registered in the browser, call
document.register, vendor
prefixed, with the first
argument is your tag name that
you want to register, and the
second is an object describing
that prototype you
just set up.
And so once you do that, this
thing returns a constructor
that you can then use as you
would normally expect.
New x-foo, document.create,
x-foo tag.
Totally standard stuff.
How about extending
existing elements?
You saw in the button is
mega-button demo, right, I
didn't like the way a
button acted, so I
wanted to extend it.
And so the way you do that in
your element definition is
with one property here.
Just extends="button".
So I create a definition for
mega-button, and I say
extends="button".
That's all you're doing.
If you want, there's the
JavaScript version.
Same example, but in the
JavaScript world.
So this time, I'll use
object.create, and instead of
inheriting from HTML element,
I'm inheriting from a
specialized version of that.
So I'm inheriting from HTML
button elements prototype.
And then you register it using
document.register, give it the
tag name, and that prototype
you've set up.
These are called type extension
custom elements, so
the button is a syntax.
And there's actually a new
overloaded version of create
element--
document.createElement--
and the first argument you give
it is the thing you want
to create, and so the button.
And the second argument is
the is portion of that.
So the button is mega-button,
and what you get back, that
would be the markup that's
created for that.
So that's a type extension
custom element.
So creating new ones, extending
existing ones.
What about template
and Shadow DOM?
I talked about that
stuff earlier.
It seems really cool.
It's hard to understand.
Where does all fit into
this picture?
And that is really that custom
elements and Shadow
DOM really are BFFs.
And so here's an example of
using that stuff I talked
about before.
If I want to encapsulate my
markup and hide it in Shadow
DOM so people can't traverse
into it, I
basically set up a template.
So I'm using HTML templates
inside of my custom element
definition.
You can see that I'm using the
@host at-rule to style my
element in a certain way.
So in this case, I'm saying hey,
please be display block
at the bottom by default,
and also have
your background yellow.
So I'm styling my x-foo-shadow
tag to be
these default styles.
I have some markup in here.
And in this case, since I have
Shadow DOM, in my registration
process, in my ready callback
when the page has seen this
element definition, I
create Shadow DOM.
So I don't just set
inner text.
I have to create this Shadow
DOM from this template.
This refers to the actual
element itself.
So that's my host node.
I'm creating Shadow DOM and
attaching it to my x-foo
shadow tag.
And I append the template
contents.
So I'll clone the content,
right, just as you saw from
earlier in the slides.
I'll clone that, and that's
going to be my Shadow DOM is
the clone of this template.
So the live demo at the bottom
here, instead of having
something that I can view from
the outside world and traverse
into, it's now encapsulated.
It's not only style
encapsulation, but markup
encapsulation.
So my x-foo down here, if I try
to traverse into it, you
see that document fragment
now that's been attached.
That's my Shadow DOM.
That's the hidden markup, and
inside of that is the stuff
that I filled it with.
So again, the only reason I
can do this is because dev
tools has that show Shadow
DOM flag on.
Normally, a person viewing
source would only see this
x-foo shadow tag.
So it's really, really
awesome.
That's Shadow DOM, and that's
how you use templates in
Shadow DOM inside of
a custom element.
But what about insertion
points?
So I kind of glossed
over that.
I showed you the tool.
This is where things get really,
really powerful.
I can define a my-tabs
element, right?
So this is going to be
like a tabs widget.
Inside of that, I'll
create a template.
Inert markup until I use it.
And I'll create a couple
of insertion points for
people to adhere to.
So this is my internal
structure.
I'm saying, please, markup, go
here, go here, go here, and
then I can style this inside
of my custom element
definition any way I want.
So as a user of this tag, when
somebody uses my-tabs, they
would use it like this
at the bottom, right?
They would declare
the my-tabs.
Inside of it, they could put
H2s, they could put section
tags describing the tab, the
title, and the content for it.
And so internal to my custom
element in my Shadow DOM, I
make it look like this, right?
With style encapsulation
with my Shadow DOM.
With insertion points, I can
tell the H2s to go into these
certain areas.
So these become super, super
powerful when you combine it
with all these extra goodies.
Firefox nightly has
document.register, Chrome has
document.register, and that's
why these are partially
highlighted.
The actual definition part is
not in any browser yet, but
document.register is.
You can play with it today.
So templates, Shadow DOM,
custom elements.
The last piece of this equation
is HTML imports.
HTML imports allow us to import
an entire HTML document
inside of our application.
All we have to do is declare a
link rel-- so there's a new
rel import type.
So link rel="import", and then
you reference an HTML file
anywhere on the web, right?
It can be on a CDN, it can
be local to your app.
Maybe this HTML file has a bunch
of element definitions
inside of it.
So once I do that, that's where
I get on my definitions
from, and x-foo is
defined in it.
Then I can use that
tag on my page.
So this becomes really powerful,
because then you can
start to reuse other people's
components, or you can reuse
components you've written
in the past.
So inside of awesome-menu.html,
I can link
in an x-toolbar tag somebody's
created.
I can link in a menu item
somebody's created.
And when I'm creating this
awesome menu, this new tag
that I'm defining in HTML,
I can use that work.
So whether it's mine, somebody
else's, totally cool.
And so this is an example of a
custom element using other
custom elements.
Kind of boggles your mind.
But it's super, super handy, and
really, really powerful.
At the bottom, this is what
somebody would use.
My awesome menu.
They would just instantiate the
tag, and they would link
rel import that.
Very, very cool.
This one is not supported
anywhere yet.
But it's polyfilled, so you
can check out the session
after this to learn
more about it.
So templates, right?
Inert chunks of markup
to be reused later.
Shadow DOM for encapsulatable
styles in DOM.
Custom elements--
that will give us the actual
definitions of how we create a
new element in HTML.
And HTML imports allow us to
then import, whether it's a
document, whether it's element
definitions, any HTML into our
own document.
So hopefully you guys sort of
see the zen moment here, which
is pretty cool.
It's very powerful.
It's thinking about building
apps in a declarative HTML
way, which is different
than we're currently
thinking about it.
A couple of inspiring demos,
just for kicks.
So we can create a meme gen
tag, which is pretty cool.
So this is a coworker, Seth
Ladd, and he's on
a beach right now.
And I have content
editable here.
Sup Google IO.
Web rocks!
And so I've set a click listener
for an on change
event on this input, so this is
internal to my widget and
my component.
I can change its background, so
he can be now on the Golden
Gate Bridge in San Francisco.
Can throw him over an NYC
if he needs to be.
So again, and it's just
a tag, right?
So this is what somebody would
declare on their page.
They would give it a source,
I've defined it an attribute
on my element, just as
with normal HTML.
And then inside of it, they
have H1s and H2s for those
headers, and so those are
insertion points, then, being
funneled in to my
custom element.
But it's also about thinking
about apps, right?
So you can kind of encapsulate
and encompass whole
functionality into a tag now.
So I can create a photo booth
tag, and its sole purpose is
to basically just wrap the get
user media APIs to do a photo
booth effect in the browser.
We're going to get this
to work, you guys.
OK, we're not going
to get it to work.
But you can imagine my face
going through this, and
there's CSS filters and stuff.
But very cool.
So using other parts of the web
platform, like new parts,
like web RTC, wrap it
in a tag, right?
So now I have basically an app
within an app, and all
somebody has to do is link,
import this into your app, and
you've got that functionality
for free.
So can you try this today?
The answer is totally you
can try this today.
Apart from that last demo,
everything worked as expected.
You can enable a couple feature
flags in Chrome Canary.
I definitely recommend
Chrome Canary.
It's got the experimental web
features flag that you can
enable, experimental JavaScript
features flag.
If you're trying Shadow DOM,
trying to understand that
crazy complex, please show
Shadow DOM in the dev tools,
enable that.
Super, super handy.
If you want to follow at least
Chrome and Blink's
implementation of the web
component stuff, there's this
hot list that you can link to.
I'll have a link to the
slides at the end, so
don't take it down.
But sort of in flight,
low level stuff.
If you want to know about where
this stuff is in flight,
check out the session
right after this.
It's about all these
polyfill libraries
that I've showed you.
All the live demos.
That's what the stuff
is using.
So plug for that.
You don't even have to
move in this room.
This session's going to be up
at webcomponentsshift.com.
Again, I'm going to put in on
GitHub, so there's my GitHub
link down there.
I really appreciate
you guys' time.
Thanks for tuning in
on the live stream.
Thank you.